so in one of the crazier legal things
that i've heard in a very long time
lady gaga's dogs were apparently
kidnapped or i guess
dog-napped and people are wondering what
were the actual crimes that were
committed here well there were a bunch
and as much as we love
dogs and they are a part of the family
they are also considered property so
it is theft its conversion to try and
steal someone's dog many states
including california have specific laws
about trying to take someone's dog
but on top of that these robbers
actually used a gun and shot the dog
walker who was
walking lady gaga's dog now that is
aggravated robbery when you use a deadly
weapon to commit a robbery
that is what makes it aggravated so
that's clearly a crime there but the
fact that shot the dog walker means that
this also qualifies as
attempted murder as well and we're just
lucky that the dog walker survived
thankfully the dogs have been returned
but if these criminals are ever found
they're going to jail for a very very
long time
so as always subscribe or i'll see you
in court